Hey guys,
In this video I'm
going to give you five important reasons why
you need to join a men's Bible study group.
The first reason is because Proverbs 27:17 says:
[Proverbs 27:17]
You know, we are in this world but we're
not part of this world, and so even though
there's a lot of darkness in this world, the
best friends that you can make are those who
take their relationship with God seriously.
Godly men, who you can trust with your life.
Men who inspire you and
motivate you to become better.
Men who are there to be a friend who listens
when things are tough and a brother who holds you
accountable for when you act up or make mistakes.
A Bible study group for men is an ideal place
where you can meet other brothers in Christ.
Men who are serious with God.
That is the place where where you can also
meet a good friend, maybe even a best friend.
Someone that you can call a brother.
A brother for a life, that will help
you to walk this temporary world
that's full of darkness but to walk
it the right way with Christ as your focus point.
Is it not interesting that when Jesus sent out the
disciples, He sent them out two by two.
Read it with me.
[Luke 10:1]
You know, I personally have a handful of men that
I trust fully that I can go to and ask for advice.
Godly men that I know are serious with God.
And when I ask them to pray for me or talk
about certain issues then I know they
really care about me and have the best
of intentions for me and they will go
to God and pray with me and for me.
Even when I'm not talking to them.
If you don't have men like that in
your life - brothers - then pray to God.
Ask him to send you men that you can trust,
that you can build a strong relationship
with moving forward until the day you die.
And then start joining a men's Bible
study group this week if you can.
The second reason is God wants us to
have fellowship with other believers.
You know I've heard some men say,
well, I don't want to go to church,
because church, it's just full of fake people.
Well, first of all, the church is not a place
for people who are perfect.
You will find sinners there
because all of us are sinners.
It is a place for broken people who
know they need God desperately.
People like you.
And me.
We all have that sinful nature
in us and we will have it until the day we die.
No one is perfect, and so when you go to church,
don't expect to find perfect people.
You will find unbelievers there.
You'll also find people who are new Christians.
Babies in Christ.
And then you will also find other
people who are mature Christians.
And even they still make mistakes, because all of
us still have that sinful fleshly nature in us.
We go to church for different reasons and so
the first thing is we go to church for God.
To learn, to grow together.
That's why we go, so instead of
judging other people, look at the log in your
own eye first before you judge other people.
Because Christ came for sinners, not for
those people who think they're perfect.
The second reason you go to church is not just so
that you can get fed the whole time with spiritual
milk, so that you can just grow and grow and grow
and you're just sitting there and becoming fat.
Spiritually fat.
No.
It's also there, the church, because
you need to go and help people.
You need to contribute.
It's not just about you.
And third, the church is not the building.
The church is where brothers and sisters
come together in Christ, to worship God.
That's a church.
So that means a
Bible study group is also the Church of God.
And then four, God tells us to go to church.
It is not something that we can decide.
It is what scripture says.
So you need to decide - do you want to listen
to your fleshly, sinful nature that tells you
I don't want to go to church?
Or to God that says go?
[Hebrews 10:24-25]
The third reason why you need to go to a men's
Bible study is because men are different, right?
Women are different.
Men talk about different things.
And there are things that you need to hear
from other men that's grounded in scripture.
Like, how to be a good father.
How to be a good husband.
How to be a good man according to the Bible.
[1 Corinthians 16:13-14]
You know, men can be very childish.
I'm talking about men
who are not reborn Christians.
Their way of thinking is still worldly, you know?
Especially if you have a group of men and their
egos and they're just puffed up and you see - but
what you learn when you join a men's Bible study
is to change your way of thinking - living - and
acting - according to God's Word.
And so you leave those childish things behind.
[1 Corinthians 13:11]
You know, there's something beautiful and special
about men coming together to pray together,
read scripture together, and worship God.
You know, it is ...
I keep on thinking about certain men like David.
You know, men who are there,
who say here I am Lord.
Change me, take out everything that is not right.
Men who are serious with God.
When they come together and they pray
for each other, they worship God.
That is special.
And if you join a group like that, you will
become a stronger man and grow in Christ.
You'll become a mature man.
Mature reborn Christian.
The fourth reason is you can
learn from good role models.
There are many older men that
I grew to respect and admire.
Men who are spiritually mature and who already
walked the life I now walk, carrying with them an
immense amount of experience that I learn from.
So this is where you get mentors,
role models, that you can learn from.
And we need to learn from these kind of people
that already walked most of the path - the journey
of sanctification - that you are walking on now.
And still going to walk on.
They went through many challenges.
They're almost done with their journey.
The next step for them is almost heaven.
These are people who are over 60 - 70 - 80 years
old, so they completed most of their race already.
Victoriously.
Learning how to overcome challenges through
biblical principles, values, and also commands.
Things that we have to do so they learn not just
to be hearers of the Word, but to be doers.
And we also need to learn from their mistakes,
just like we can learn from the
mistakes of the Nation of Israel.
[1 Corinthians 10:6-10]
Now listen to this:
[1 Corinthians 10:11]
The fifth reason is identity, purpose and growth.
You will grow spiritually a lot faster in a
men's Bible study compared to being alone.
Through this time, you will also feel like
you're part of God's family.
You have purpose.
And you also find your
identity as a man in Christ.
[Ephesians 2:10]
Now, if you're still looking
for a men's Bible study group,
remember you can also create your own, right?
And if you're already in a men's Bible study
group and you're looking for a devotional
- something to work through - a study
guide - then get Bold Pursuit, a 90-day
devotional for men seeking the heart of God.
I wrote this specifically for men.
I'll add all the details for you
in the video description down below
with also the study group questions.
You can also get it on my website,
dlm-christianlifestyle.com or Boldpursuitbook.com.
Now, just so you know what this book
is all about, I wrote this book for
men to bring them back to scripture, so
that they can become true men of God.
And pursue God with everything in them.
Let me read some of the back cover here for you.
You could pursue a lot of things in life
- money - relationships - power - but
only one pursuit brings satisfaction on earth.
Because only one pursuit matters for eternity.
Becoming a true man of God.
I think about men like David, you know,
who took their relationship with God seriously.
Who prayed and said God, search my heart and
take out everything that is not right.
And God looked at David and He called
David a man after My own heart.
You know, we can have that same
relationship with God today.
The action-oriented teachings
in Bold Pursuit will challenge and equip you to
pursue God above all else in your daily life.
As you dig deep into God's Word, you'll
experience the fulfillment of making your
relationship with Jesus your greatest priority.
Through each day's straightforward devotional
reading, packed with powerful
biblical insights, you'll explore
how to worship God in Spirit and in truth.
What it means to engage in spiritual battle.
What sin is and isn't.
And why it matters.
Where to find hope when you're feeling hopeless.
Practical ways to overcome
destructive habits and addictions.
And, how to make Bible study and
prayer an integrated part of your life.
Each daily reading in Bold Pursuit combines a
Bible passage with a short devotional that speaks
to the real issues men face at work and home.
Prayer prompts, reflection questions,
and action items bring focus to each day.
In an age of distraction and busyness,
every man's true calling remains the same: to walk
with the God who created you for great things,
and find the meaning and purpose your soul craves.
I talk a lot in this book about the difference
between acting - living in the
Spirit - and not in the flesh.
And what it means to truly come to that
place where you fully surrender to Christ.
You know, Jesus asked Peter in John 21:15:
[John 21:15-17]
You know, you've probably heard this a lot by now,
that God is love, and He loves you and
He does, it's true, but do you love Him?
Do you love Jesus with everything that is in you?
This book lets you focus on the right things.
Your relationship with Jesus.
And so check it out when you
have some time and if you are serious about your
relationship with God, watch these videos here.
Remember to subscribe and I'll see you there.
And always remember, life is short.
So don't waste yours.
Bye.